from above
mario paul looks like it's had the life
sucked out of it
people's homes
now frozen in time
eerie carcasses of war
and on the ground
even the dead get no peace
it's too dangerous to bury them in the
cemetery
often lying outside for days
those left alive can't make sense of
this war
mercury
my mother-in-law born in 1936 she
survived the leading grad siege russian
passport honored worker of russian
federation's fishing industry there she
is lying
those killed in the bombardment are
being buried in the grounds of their
homes
something they never would have imagined
while living here
it's disgusting i'm not going to blame
anyone i'm disgusted i'm scared and i'm
cold it's a horror i have never expected
this to happen in my life
this video has been uploaded by the
chechen leader ramzan kadyrov
fighting for russia
claiming this is an attempt to evacuate
civilians
but most efforts to evacuate civilians
from here have so far failed
for three weeks russia has assaulted the
strategic port city
tens of thousands are trapped here and
nothing functions anymore
we spend two days in the basement she's
a sick woman who had to sit on a chair
all that time i thought she wouldn't
survive
then the men came and helped to carry
her out so we are here all bundled up
with blankets it's very cold we just
want to go home
young faces still manage a smile
in these unimaginable times
everything is going to be okay she tells
her children it will end soon
vladimir putin says russian forces are
not targeting civilians the ground
the reality
tells a very different story
stephanie decker al-jazeera in western
ukraine